It's great to welcome Brian GREENE to the
program today, who's a professor of physics
and mathematics and director of Columbia University's
Center for Theoretical Physics, also known
for his groundbreaking discoveries in superstring
theory.
And author of many books including I believe
most recently it's until the end of time,
right?
That's your latest.
Yes, that's correct.
Exactly.
So maybe to get into our conversation when
somebody maybe is trying to understand not
something like superstring theory or the nuts
and bolts, but more generally, what types
of questions does your work seek to answer
to?
To have a broader understanding of what you're
doing?
How would you explain that to them?
Well, certainly in my news book that you just
made reference to until the end of time, the
goal is to give the curious person a sense
of how they fit within the cosmic hole.
I mean, the journey that I take in that book
is from the very beginning of time, walking
through the sequence of steps that, you know,
life and conscious beings and on to the very
far future.
And within that cosmic unfolding, my goal
is to give the person a sense of where they
came from, the environment that they're in
now, where it came from and where things are
going with ultimately a new perspective on
why things matter.
Does the day to day of sort of like imagine
thinking of superstring theory, for example,
when you're working on something like superstring
theory?
Does it feel like it's connected directly
to answering those questions or does it feel
like it starts to get removed and sort of
operate in a more theoretical space?
Well, we like to use the big questions as
motivation.
We deeply want to know the full story of creation,
the full story of how the universe began.
We'd love to understand the deep nature of
space and time.
These kinds of questions are why many of us
certainly.
For me, it's the case went into the field
in the first place.
But your question is a good one, because when
you're in the midst of doing the research,
it's like any other subject.
The detail, the daily grind, if you will,
can often be fairly disconnected from the
big overarching goals.
So, you know, I have students that come to
me and they want to work in physics and all
they have in mind are the big, huge questions.
And when I describe them, I hate to make progress
toward those questions.
You've got to do mathematical calculations,
you gotta do experiments, you've got to write
computer programs, you've got to do simulations.
For many of them, that's a bit of a shock.
But that's the way you make progress in the
day to day sense.
How would you sort of ballpark the progress
that has been made like over the last 10,
50 and 200 years on answering some of these
questions?
In other words, there's camps that say we're
never really going to know the origins because
we can't can't really go back in a way that
would give us those answers.
There's others who say maybe we will, but
like aside from the end point that we may
or may not get, too.
What's the what's been the progress that has
been made?
Well, it's been utterly stunning, right?
If you if you go to the furthest extent of
the timeline that you mentioned, go back 200
years to say the early eighteen hundreds.
We were just beginning to gain an understanding
of some of the most rudimentary forces at
work in the universe, how electricity and
magnetism worked.
The early experiments are just taking place,
experiments on the nature of light.
These were vital developments.
But when you compare them with what we understand
today, the insights that have come from special
relativity, Einstein generativity again, Einstein
quantum mechanics and on through the developments
in unification that have swept through the
20th century and into the 21st.
I mean, right now we can do mathematical calculations
that tell us what the universe is like a fraction
of a second after the beginning.
And then we can use those mathematical insights
to make predictions for what those conditions
way back then should yield.
For our observations today.
And many of those predictions are borne out
to fantastic accuracy by powerful equipment
that we launch into space that takes the temperature
of the night sky that looks deep into the
heart of black holes.
So it is stunning how far we've come in the
last 200 years.
What do you think has been the effect of that
on sort of the human psyche as we exist in
the world?
And the reason I ask.
I mean, is it we also it's hard to separate
that from technological advance medical science.
Changing so drastically.
Travel like it.
It's difficult because those things have also
changed so much.
But what's your sense of how our understanding
and day to day lives are different based on
what we now know that we didn't 200 years
ago?
Well, I don't think you can give a uniform
blanket answer for all human minds.
There are some of us who are deeply interested
in these ideas, even if we're not doing research
on the topic and have allowed the insights
of modern science to affect our outlook on
the world and given us the laudable perspective
that there are true qualities of reality that
research both experimental and theoretical
equipment, together with, say, mathematical
insights, can reveal.
There are others, though, who enjoy the fruits
of those undertakings.
As you mentioned, the technology that has
emerged from the deeper understanding, but
have not taken in that mindset.
And it's really unfortunate, especially in
the situations that we find ourselves in today,
when there are some who feel that reality
ultimately is a matter of opinion.
It's not a matter of opinion.
I'm not trying to downgrade the value of opinions
on certain issues.
But in terms of true qualities of reality
here on planet Earth and in the wider cosmos,
there is such a thing as right and wrong.
There is such a thing as fact and fiction.
There is such a thing as expertise that can
yield insights that can determine the correct
course of action on vital issues.
And not everyone has taken in this basic quality
of scientific advancement over the past two,
three hundred years.
Right.
Well, so I mean, now we have the phrase alternative
facts is an interesting one that that has
surfaced.
And these ideas of, you know, if I don't like
your conclusion, I can just kind of reject
the premises that you use to build that up.
Do you think that that's been more acutely
weaponized recently in society?
It certainly has.
Especially when you've got leaders who have
that very perspective, or at least leaders
who leverage that perspective by using it
as a tool or as you describe as a weapon to
advance certain political perspectives.
And that is deeply troubling.
And as we're beginning to see, has the capacity
to yield deep tragedy.
What's the solution in your mind to that?
Because I've read some interesting pieces
that say it's not as simple as we have to
start teaching critical thinking and philosophy
and epistemology earlier that there's a bigger
divide and a bigger picture issue than than
simply that.
I agree, although I would say that that is
part of the solution.
I. I can't help the optimistic side of my
personality from saying I just feel that if
we could get kids at an early stage to really
recognize the power of scientific insight,
not abstractly.
But, you know, I've taught kids and I've seen
them undergo that transition from confusion
about something to mastery, even if it's a
small element of math or physics.
And that move from confusion to clarity can
be life changing because your way of thinking
about the world and your recognition of your
power to understand the world can radically
change.
But I agree, that's not the full.
It's not the full solution, because we find
ourselves in an era when many people and by
many I don't exactly know the number that
I'm talking about.
So don't hold me to sort of details of numbers
here.
But there is a segment of the population that
makes decisions not based on thinking through
policy, but rather who else is supporting
that policy.
It's the group think it's whether or not you
want to be on that group or the other group
as opposed to a rational evaluation of policy
and perspective.
And that kind of identity politics needs to
needs to shift because that is not the appropriate,
useful way to set policy.
Yeah, I'm curious what you would think about
the motivations of those.
So let's just to give an example.
The Tea Party in 2010.
Right.
This was a movement that succeeded to the
extent that it did because of individuals
voting for people who were pushing policies
that were not going to be good for them as
individuals.
But like Jonathan hydt, for example, argues
they were policies that.
Identified as good for the group in which
they were members or a membership maybe is
a bit of a too formal a term for it, isn't
that kind of individual versus group thinking
a factor in what you're describing here?
It's huge.
It's exactly what I'm describing.
You know, if you were to and Jonathan probably
did because he is a great social scientist
and goes out and gets the data.
I imagine that they've collected data.
If you interview the very people who are supporting
a given policy and ask them why they are supporting
it.
Some will have thought it through, no doubt,
but many will not have thought it through
because that's not the way that the decision
is made.
Rather, the decision is made in the manner
that you describe.
Do you want to be identified as being part
of that group of people who, for whatever
reason, you feel more of a kinship with?
Or do you want to break ranks with the group
that you feel that kinship with in order to
follow a policy that is not widely accepted
by the initial group?
And unfortunately, that kind of perspective
and that kind of decision making is prevalent
and it's not the kind of decision making that
ultimately is good for the world.
So to step back from zoom out from this a
tiny bit, I have this idea that maybe is very
naive and I'm curious what you think about
it, which is if we were to make contact with
alien intelligence and find out it's real,
if we were to figure out some of the big answers
that people in your field are looking for
about our our place in the universe, etc.,
I have this idea that issues like gay marriage
and debt and deficit and stuff like this would
evaporate because everybody would immediately
have this awakening as a result of this new
information that we have.
Is that incredibly naive, which would we just
kind of adjust and keep having the same disagreements
we're having?
Well, I think the answer depends a lot on
the details.
Right.
It's certainly the case that having a common
enemy is a powerful force of unification.
Fortunately, and unfortunately, at the same
time, when we can identify a common enemy,
it allows us to bind together into an even
larger group if that will aid in our survival.
And look, many of our predilections emerged
from evolutionary pressures across, you know,
tens of thousands of generations.
And the ability to come together into socialized
groups has been an important means by which
we have gotten to our place of dominance in
the world.
So it's not surprising that we have the sort
of inbuilt reaction to certain kinds of pressures,
certain kinds of challenges, and once a challenge
is a common enemy.
But, you know, I like to think that if we
encountered the aliens, maybe it won't be
an enemy, maybe be a very friendly relationship.
And if that were the case, maybe they would
reveal deep truths that somehow the world
would listen to.
But I have a feeling that it's and maybe over
a long stretch of time that might be possible.
But the notion that I think you are articulating
that all of a sudden we sort of lift ourselves
up from thinking about all of the issues here.
And all of this now is sort of secondary to
this larger kind of conversation we're having
having with aliens.
I suspect that would not happen, at least
not on the kinds of instantaneous timescales
that you have in mind.
Well, part of what makes me doubt it would
happen at all is that humans seem to have
this incredible ability to just adjust to
what reality becomes and it becomes the new
baseline and things sort of return to some
kind of baseline in some way.
Yeah, I no, it's certainly the case.
You know, I was on an airplane at JFK on the
tarmac on September 11th, 2001.
And I could I saw the the plane hit the tower
from my seat in the plane.
I had a clear shot right from Queens into
Manhattan.
And so there was a sense at that moment that
that the world would completely change, that
nobody would live their lives the way that
they once did.
And that was true for a while.
And there certainly have been changes that
occurred by virtue of 9/11, without a doubt.
But I think many people reverted at least
pretty close to the lives that they led if
they weren't directly part of the tragedy
or if they didn't have a loved one who is
directly part of the tragedy.
We do have this.
You can call it resilience, this ability to
sort of revert back to the way that we once
were.
And so I kind of agree.
With you that that is the default development
that we certainly have seen happen over and
over again, that we find a way of sort of
acclimating to the new environment and taking
our old lives and fitting it in to the new
jigsaw puzzle as best as we can and then going
forward from there.
Let's pause our conversation with professor
of physics and Mathematics.
Brian
GREENE there.
The
full conversation will be on The David Pakman
Show YouTube channel at YouTube.com.
Splash The David Pakman Show.